hello everybody my name is markiplier
and say hi to Betsy that's Betsy
everybody earth you're so dead
I want to do a series where I play like
counter-strike
and Jarrett yes and all I do is
smack-talk my own team the entire day
just you don't rush be you never watch
be very net spot you have a much better
angle from Guth's if you're kinda let's
short over here over whenever anyone
uses the word bod it reminds me of those
commercials for bod man body spray from
like 30 2003 was just obscene like dudes
and there were just ladies who are like
I want your bod
hot bod
I want your bah do this barrack and
Dirac was like oh my god if I get bod
man body spray no no no no please dear
God it's okay alright that's moderately
a little bit better well the old lady's
dead now I don't know why I haven't
questioned this up into this point
why why why camo lasers why Campbell
missiles why is all this happening I
mean I perfectly understand the shock is
a robo bird but I'm starting to question
why these camels are capable of shooting
lasers out of their mouths oh it's so
pretty
who are you hi I punched her why did I
punch I punched her I punched her so
hard she went into the ocean
I love the feeling of mac and cheese on
my face I love the feeling of mac and
cheese on my face I love feeling like
shouting I love feeling leather on my
testing okay okay I love feet and
leather testy balls one more time
I love feet and leather testy balls I
love fecal matter I can't help it I love
the feeling of mac and cheese on my face
who won who won who won one red one red
one there is wine to practice red one
third round baby for all the bend we did
it come on are you from markimoo central
we weren't maybe I don't know when that
left no it has not been gone a third
game oh but hey marvel market new bit
now you from our team ooh central I'm
the winner baby there's no proof winner
Photoshop I am the winner Photoshop look
it's my shrine to Santa Christmas is
right around the corner bang
OOP gods may their blessings never rain
upon my hands you need to eat meat oh I
need that meat boy not vegetables not
vegetables are bad for you kids out
there don't eat your vegetables you will
not grow up big and strong unless you're
a meat-eater like us you don't get any
pudding unless you eat your meat you
can't eat your broccoli until you eat
your meat yeah now I've said this again
you won't get your dessert of Brussels
sprouts unless you meet yeah yeah oh did
I mention we thanks for watching all of
the videos in this compilation are
available in the description so check
them out and if you'd like to see more
in the future please leave a like to let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more on a daily basis
please subscribe today or if you're
already subscribed share this video with
a friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video